by the way the american people would be
on trump's side there's a video that
went viral over the weekend
of a bunch of good old-fashioned
patriots
who were who were at a pro-police rally
and a bunch of antifa thugs organized
leftist
vandals came up and started harassing
not just a regular ordinary protester
but a guy in a wheelchair it did not end
very well for antifa
scum
these antifa guys are all wearing black
they're in full right they're gone
bye bye go home oh
here we go
[Applause]
oh my and it unfortunately turns violent
these antifa people had weapons on them
by the way
and so they they're coming out they're
harassing this guy in the wheelchair
initially they're just being chased out
of town then it seems to turn into a
brawl
finally finally the cops get there and
the antifa people start throwing punches
at the cops which
is just not not a good idea anti for
people
this is this we were talking about porn
earlier that is porn to the american
people
watching a bunch of patriots not take it
from
violent leftist thugs and then watching
then those violent leftless thugs get
arrested
that is like porn that is a crack for
the american people
because no matter what stupid nonsense
you see on the mainstream media
which pretends that the media are
left-wing and they lament out
how or they pretend that the media are
right-wing rather and they lament how
there's no left-wing media even as
they're on cnn
no matter what they say the american
people are normal
mostly normal they like their liberty
they like their cherished traditions
they don't like it when leftist thugs
harass people in wheelchairs they don't
like that
okay it does show you a lesson that
first of all if the cops are not going
to enforce order if the civil authority
is not going to enforce order
then civilians are going to do it and we
don't like vigilante justice in this
country
but someone someone will impose order
who's that going to be i don't think
antifa is turning out very well
for the the left i don't think blm
trained marxists are working very well
for the left
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you